a u.n report seeking an international
criminal court investigation into sri
lanka
is being discussed today at a meeting in
geneva the report by the un's top human
rights official michelle bachelet
also calls for sanctions against top sri
lankan officials
accused of war crimes the report accuses
the government of sri lankan president
gotabia rajapaksa
of clamping down on democracy in the
country and not
bringing to book people responsible for
rights violations
during sri lanka's decades-long civil
war for 26 years
tamil separatists battled the sri lankan
government for a separate state
the war ended in 2009 with the defeat of
the rebels
but it also left significant casualties
among the civilian population
for many of the tamils who lost loved
ones the search for accountability
has made little progress
this is the number of days these mothers
have been protesting
for four years they've stood on the side
of the road in the town of vava junia
in the north of sri lanka the women want
to know where their children and
husbands are
they've been missing since the end of
the civil war in 2009.
jayawanita kasipalai has also been here
every day for
four years she's looking for her
daughter
we need each other my suffering is also
felt by these other mothers
because of that i keep on fighting not
only for my child
but for all the children and husbands
who went missing
we have to find out what happened to our
children
all these mothers believe that their
children and loved ones will return
they can't lose their hope the 52 year
old says she recognized her daughter
in this photo from 2015. it apparently
shows the girl standing next to former
sri lankan president matripala sirisena
seeing the photos spurred her to
initiate their mother's protest
the family belongs to the tamil minority
during the last days of the civil war
they were forced to leave their home and
were taken to a camp run by sri lanka's
secret service
and interrogated on the way jaywa nita
gazipillai
says her daughter was kidnapped by whom
is unclear
shortly before the end of the civil war
in 2009 the sri lankan army combed tamil
territory
the soldiers were looking for fighters
from the tamil tiger liberation
organisation or
ltte who were fighting for independence
according to the un both warring parties
committed serious war crimes
up to fifteen thousand tamils are
officially missing
though the united nations believes the
number to be much higher
it has been impossible for this family
to find peace since their eldest child
disappeared
they've been to the police time and
again and even called on the u.n refugee
agency and the u.n human rights
commission to get involved
but in vain
it's very difficult now that my wife
stays in vanilla at the protest site
but i'm with her in thought all the time
and i keep telling my wife to bring our
daughter home
[Music]
protests by sri lanka's tamils are
growing
thousands took to the streets for three
days in early february demanding the
government clarify what happened to the
countless missing
sri lanka's current president gotabaya
rajapaksa declared all missing persons
deceased in 2020
including the daughter of geoanita
kasipalai
rajapaksa was the defence minister
during the civil war
the un commissioner for human rights
lays the blame for alleged atrocities
committed during that war
on rajapaksa's current army chief
the women simply want to know what
happened to their children
so far no sri lankan government has
offered to help them
and for some perspective on this i'm
joined now from colombo by ambika
sadkunanathan a former member of the
human rights commission
of sri lanka welcome ambika why is it so
hard for victims of a civil war that
tore the country apart to get any
justice
well i think it's difficult for the
victims to get any justice
because this government in particular
denies that there was even an ethnic
conflict
hence the root causes of those con of
the conflict have still not been
addressed
and the victims uh cannot find justice
for instance
uh we have a number of people who have
disappeared forcibly disappeared
the government now says that those
people
were all part of the ltte and hence
under
of humanitarian law that deaths are
justified
hence there is a culture of denial and a
culture of impunity
in this context victims find it very
difficult to have their voices
even heard let alone actually you know
uh get truth and justice now human
rights commissioner
michel bashili says in a report that
events over the past year
in sri lanka have caught eroded
democratic checks and balances and civic
space
and reprised a dangerous exclusionary
and majoritarian
discourse is she right
she is i mean i'm sad to say but she is
right because
we have seen since the election of the
new government in november 2019
is a concentration of power in the
executive
we have seen the 20th amendment to the
constitution which also
uh has provisions which undermine the
independence of the judiciary
and also undefined undermine the
independence of
let's say the human rights commission in
addition we also see
rapid militarization there is shrinking
of civic space
particularly in the conflict affected
north and the east
where civil society organizations are
subject to surveillance
intimidation and harassment by security
agencies
we find people are self-censoring and
there is
a climate of fear that if you are
critical of the government there might
be reprisals or you will be called the
traitor
international we are talking about a
country ambika
that has emerged from more than two
decades of civil war
the kinds of things you are describing
should apparently be the
exactly the kinds of things that a
government should avoid and therefore i
wonder why is the government of gotavia
rajapaksa pursuing this agenda
i mean that's a very good question and i
think it goes to the
fact that historically we have had a
majoritarian state
uh and of course now more so this
government in particular practices
ethno-nationalist politics
and i think they do not view the
minorities or the numerical minorities
the tamils and the muslims
as equal citizens and hence uh there is
in a way you can find
contempt like the force cremations of
muslims who have died of covet
in that climate to them in according to
their ethos values and strategies
i suppose this would make total sense
do you think there is a danger ambika
that this sort of an agenda from the
government
could give rise to a new cycle of
violence in the country
i think this kind of intolerance
discrimination
is what led to the the ethnic conflict
that we had we
suffered with it for like 30 years the
root causes have still not been
addressed
we also uh can find this is the kind of
intolerance
uh bigotry and discrimination that can
lead to
radicalization of the youth in that
context we have covet we have severe
economic
uh hardships that people are facing at
the moment
i think all that is a recipe for
definitely more
more violence in society and potentially
down the line
uh perhaps another conflict
uh michelle bartlett has called for
international action
including targeted sanctions and taking
the matter to the
international criminal court are those
the only avenues left
to achieve reconciliation and human
rights accountability in sri lanka
i would say right now yes because uh
domestically there
is a culture of denial as i said and
they feel that there is nothing to even
deal with there is no need to deal with
the past
so there are no domestic remedies that
the victims can
access although i know very well that
the international
uh mechanism is uh you know faulty and
it's not
perfect right now for the victims that
is the only option they have
in their long march towards truth and
justice
ambiguous and we leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
joining us thank you
thank you